-It's so nice to be here!
-Is that real gold?
-It's real gold, you guys.
-Wow! Oh, my gosh!
-Paid for by Jimmy Fallon.
-Yeah, of course.
I buy everyone
golden dresses, yeah.
-No, I've been meaning to tell
you for a year,
I did a movie in
your home city of Saugerties.
-Yeah.
-And, you guys,
Jimmy is like a god there.
There's pictures of him,
like, in restaurants and stuff.
-Saugerties, New York.
Shout-out.
Thank you for bringing that up.
-Yeah.
-Hi, Saugerties.
-Yeah. Hi, Saugerties.
-I love that.
-Yeah.
-Come back when
the movie comes out.
-I'd love to.
It was very cold.
-Yeah, it was.
Saugerties is very, very --
Well, you're back in New York.
-I'm back!
-You're in studio.
Thank you for doing this.
-I'm so happy to be here.
It feels so nice.
I got here the day the
marathon -- or, actually,
the hour the marathon was ending
right in front of my hotel.
-Wow!
-And I had to pull my bags
like five blocks,
but I wasn't even mad,
because it's so nice
to see people, like,
out and about, doing things.
It's great.
-New York is the greatest at
this time of year, too.
-It's the best.
-It's gorgeous.
-Yeah.
-Did you bring the dogs?
-Unfortunately, the dogs
are back in L.A.,
getting the full L.A. treatment,
but I'll be back
in a couple of days.
They live a good life, though.
They're fine.
-They live a fantastic life.
I follow you on the socials.
-The Instagram.
-On the Instagrams,
the Twitters.
Here's Ethel, I want to say.
-This is real. This is me.
Yeah, so, this was about
midway through 2020,
when I was just
buying random things online,
and I got a new dog named Ethel,
who's in there,
if you can see her.
And it's like
a BabyBjorn for a small puppy.
I'm the crazy dog lady.
-You are.
-Clearly, yeah.
-But do you let
the dog walk ever?
-Oh, she was like 2 months old
at that point,
and she couldn't walk --
She can walk now.
I let the dog walk.
Yeah, I let her walk. Yeah.
Oh, there's more.
-But do you let the dog walk?
That's a different dog.
-This is a different dog.
-You've got to try
walking the dog.
-Yeah,
but they get tired, Jimmy,
and, like, their paws get dirty.
Like, we have to
watch out for that.
But this was also
about midway through 2020.
-Yeah.
-And I believe there's one more.
-Yeah, there's one more.
You literally put a dog
in a BabyBjorn at this point.
And this is actually --
You actually took it
to the that level.
-I wasn't even
doing this jokingly.
Like, this was
a serious purchase.
And he was clearly a little --
He was thrilled about it,
as well.
-Yeah, you could tell.
-Yeah. Those are my children.
I love them.
-I saw you did something on --
Was it TikTok where
you did the --
Or, no, Instagram.
-Nope.
Yeah, Instagram, probably.
-Was it Instagram?
-Yeah.
-Was it the Toddler Challenge?
Oh, it's the Toddler Challenge.
So, where parents were doing it
with their kids,
and they were putting out candy
and saying,
"I'm going to go away.
Don't eat this. Don't eat this."
And I was like -- Some kids
were obviously very naughty,
and I was like,
"You know who would probably
do very well at this?
My dog Elvis."
So I did it with my dog Elvis,
and he's a perfect creature.
-You brought us the video.
Let's take a look at this.
-Oh, you do. Okay.
-Yeah.
-You can have these treats,
but you're going to have to
wait till I get back, okay?
No. You got to wait
till I'm back, alright?
Promise?
Okay.
Don't have them.
I'll be right back.
-What a good -- what a good...
-I'm back!
Elvis, you're such a good boy!
You're such a good boy!
Okay, you can have them.
Here you go.
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
-What a good boy.
-He's the goodest boy.
I love him so much.
-I want to talk about
your series on AMC+.
-Yes.
-"Ragdoll."
It's from the same people
who did "Killing Eve."
-Yeah.
-How do we set this up?
-So, I do have to say,
for all the people
who have supported me
in my past projects,
it's really dark.
It's very disturbing.
I mean, within five minutes
of the show,
you see a body strung
from the ceiling,
and it's six body parts sewn
together to create the ragdoll.
It's dark, but --
-You think?
-Yeah. Yeah. We go there.
-Wow!
-But what makes it more
manageable is,
there's this, like,
really incredible dark humor,
like they did with
"Killing Eve."
-Yeah.
-It was so much fun.
I got to do the whole thing
in London, and that was --
-Are you a fan of
true-crime stuff?
-The biggest.
My mom and sister
and I have a thread
with our favorite
true-crime podcasts.
And I feel like I've
unintentionally been preparing
for this show my whole life,
because I'm the first
to watch those types of thing.
I tend to like
the darker things.
-Yeah. But it's good
and it is --
Like you said, there is --
I know it doesn't sound funny,
but there are jokes.
But "Killing Eve," they do
a great job of that, as well.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Congrats on this.
-Thank you so much.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lucy Hale in "Ragdoll."
Take a look.
-I know the media coverage
helps people to make
very detailed fake confessions,
but don't we have to entertain
the possibility
that one of them
could be genuine?
Have you ever been wrong
about someone?
-No.
I don't know how you
come back from that.
You'd never be able to trust
your instincts again.
-Yeah.
Sometimes, it feels like
only our mistakes have
any consequences.
-Lucy Hale, everybody.
New episodes of "Ragdoll"
are available
every Thursday on AMC+.